Let's go next to our caller from the eight
one, two area code. Who's calling today from
eight? One two.
Hello? Yeah. Oh, Hey David. A big fan. I think
half my family watches your show. What's your
name? No, I wanted
to, I wanted to, um, what'd you say?
I said, what's your name? Where you're calling
from?
Oh Gosh, I'm from Bloomington. Great. Uh,
I wanted to ask you, hello?
Yes, I hear, I'm hearing you. I hear you.
No, I wanted to ask you about tax policy because
uh, a lot of people have this a dumb idea
on the right that uh, my taxes only go towards
something that makes sense. That benefits
me. Yeah. People in the right say, well, why
are my taxes going towards, um, some poor
person's health care? Or Why am I taxes going
towards some person's education? And these
are people in their last year even say it
now to where a year people are like p Buddha
judges say that, oh, why are we subsidizing
a tuition agree cottage by, are we subsidizing
a wealthy person's education? And I wanted
to ask you what your opinions on it are because
personally I think it's a really dumb idea.
This whole notion that, oh my taxes should
only go towards something that I think makes
sense. Instead of hey, we're going to collect
taxes and collectively decide where they need
to go. So
yeah, so listen, I think there's a very fair
criticism which is that the individual has
relatively little say over where their taxes
go. Like if I don't like where tax money is
going at the federal level, I can try to get
a different senator and member of Congress
elected and they would be one out of a hundred
or 435 votes respectively. Like it's very
difficult for what I want to be done with,
with tax money to be made policy. That's a
very fair criticism of the system that we
have with regard to this idea that you know,
the tax money needs to be spent on what I
want. It's all the me, me, me. What I want
idea that you hear on tax policy from the
right. You can't run a country that way. I
mean humans, once you get beyond 150 people
or so, you need some structure, some infrastructure
that will be deputized to make decisions in
ways that hopefully are representative of
what people want.
I mean, if you read guns, germs and steel
by Jared diamond, he goes, he explains this
in detail. When you look at hunter gatherer
bands, have a few families and then growing,
uh, you know, into fiefdoms and tribes like
a v you just need some kind of system. And
it is a system that one of its faults is not
the desires of every individual. CanNot impossibly
all be made reality, but the alternatives
are anarchic chaos. That's the thing. The
right usually will, if you press them on it,
they'll say, well, just whoever has the biggest
guns gets to decide
or
you have no taxation whatsoever. And everybody
just keeps all their money and builds a little
piece of road and charges people to use it
or whatever. You get into these libertarian
fantasies. So it's, it's extraordinarily immature.
Often when people go in this direction with
tax policy arguments.
So is that how you say, are you people on
the rise? You, are you at this mode of thinking
that, you know, in a democracy we can't possibly,
um, have your voice be amplified for, uh,
wherever you think taxes should be allocated
or
no, it's true. The question is, I would concede
that in a country of 340 million people, it's
completely impractical. Yeah. For every individual
to say, here's how my tax money is spent.
That the way we make our voices heard is through
the elected officials that we put in power,
that obviously many of them have been corrupted
by the campaign finance system and corporations
and super pacs and all of that. And that's
what we need to change and focus the area
to focus the conversation there.
Yeah. Thank you.
All right, thanks for the call. I very much
appreciate it.
Take a quick break. If you're holding, don't
hang up because I will go right back to the
phones. When we come back at six one seven,
eight three zero 47 50. Don't hang up. Going
right back to the phone.